I've talked about containerization on
this channel before but this video is
different because it includes the phrase
hundred-ton autonomous robots New
Zealand is a long way from almost
everywhere else on the planet humans
only reached here about 700 years ago if
you look at a globe of the earth in
almost every direction for thousands of
miles
there's nothing but ocean which means
that the ports of Auckland here and the
other ports like it all around the
country are vital to keeping New Zealand
the fantastic thing about the ports of
Auckland is we're right in the middle of
the city but the downside of that is
that we're quite constrained we're not
in their 60s when you could just pave
over everything and build out into the
harbour we can't expand anymore so we've
got a fixed footprint not so great when
your city's growing at a massive rate or
not when you get your head around the
fact you can't do the old-fashioned
things like just keep reclaiming land it
becomes quite an exciting challenge how
do we put the maximum number of
containers through this little pot of
land like every other major port in the
world
almost all the goods that arrive or
leave here are going to be in a
standardised shipping container for
incoming goods once a container has been
unlocked from the ship
these giant key cranes take it and move
it down to ground level and then it's
moved to a holding area by a straddle
carrier ready for a truck or a train to
take down the last miles of its journey
those straddle carriers look like
something out of an old Gerry Anderson
show but they're real they weigh 70 tons
before they even pick up a container and
the newest straddle carriers which are
being tested right here right now are
automated fully loaded that is a hundred
ton robot just moving around at speed
we are automating while still operating
the terminal as absolutely crazy thing
to do but we have to do it because it's
our space limitations so it's a bit like
you're having open-heart surgery while
you're still playing tennis so we're now
getting robots which can work much more
steadily and stack higher and step
closer together and so we can get a lot
more capacity out of our same piece of
land it's really really precisely a
Strads can stack containers within a net
with an accuracy of a couple of
centimeters that actually can pose a
problem because the wear and tear on the
pavement is always in the same place at
the same time so we've got a fairly cool
solution to that which is called stack
shuffling so in a man terminal of course
for the the straddle operators to know
where to put the containers we paint
lines on the ground over a number of
years that that wears out the pavement
we get ruts where the straddles drive
repetitively and damage on the asphalt
where the container corners land all the
time and of course that then requires
repair which is disruptive and expensive
so with a Strads
they refer of course to an electronic
map that they need no lines on the
ground so that enables us to then move
the container stacks just a little bit
and that spreads the wear and tear on
the pavement over a much longer period
of time GPS isn't quite precise enough
for this job and there's a lot of flat
steel surfaces that could reflect or
block those signals so there's a local
positioning system installed here as
well
synchronized transmitters all around the
port what like military GPS satellites
and equipment on each straddle carrier
triangulates the location using the
light speed delay from each one which is
literally sub nanosecond precision they
don't just look at the timing signal
itself they track the phase of each
transmitters carrier signal the locator
system is our system for the so called
positioning of the machines we have
these two antennas on top of each
machine in order to also be aware of the
orientation of the machine at each
moment but it's a local system
everything which is directly related to
the main safety of the straddle carriers
on the straddle carrier also the
navigation itself happens on the
straddle carrier whilst we're automating
a large part of our operation we're
actually keeping people in a part of it
so we'll actually have interactions
between man straddle carriers and
automated stroke areas and that's never
been done in this way anywhere else in
the world before the system has multiple
layers of safety the first one is the
simplest which is we put a big fence
around the the term we keep people out
beyond that then we've got a computer
system that monitors where all the
machines are all the time so it's both
demand and the automated travels it
manages the interactions between those
machines and it's a standalone failsafe
system and then as a sort of last layer
of defense the ace trades have laser
scanners on them which will detect the
presence of an obstacle in front of the
machine and stop it before there's a
collision we've got a different type of
automation here we have straddle
carriers there
only automated than part of the terminal
and the reason we've done that is again
the throughput so our crane drivers are
really fast so under the crane which got
lots and lots of steel it's really hard
to get those signals and automate so by
keeping manual operations underneath
these cranes here and then automating
the yard we get more capacity the robots
do the really boring stuff like moving
containers around digging out the bottom
one to put it on a truck and the people
do the really tricky stuff you know the
technology will no doubt improve but for
now that mixture of people and robots is
the perfect mix thank you to all the
team at the Port of Oakland pull down
the description for more about them and
their work
you